le président a choisi de suspendre les
audiences jusqu'au 30 novembre les
avocats tant de la défense que de la
partie civile ne souhaitait pas une
reprise en visioconférence avec le
principal accusé ali riza polak qui est
en effet atteint du coc vide et donc le
procès s'était interrompue le 2 novembre
mais il est toujours pris de symptômes
tels que des vomissements et ne peut
être donc présents physiquement alors
eric dupond moretti le 18 novembre a
signé une ordonnance qui permet le
recours à la visioconférence pour cali
risa pohlad comparaissent avec ou sans
son accord et cela avait indigné les
avocats des parties civiles mais aussi
de la défense qui estime que l'accusé a
le droit de construire sa défense de
d'interagir avec son avocat et surtout
de ne pas être jugée en étant malade il
avait fait paraître une tribune ce week
end ils ont en quelque sorte manifesté
ce matin dans l'enceinte du tribunal ils
ont eu gain de cause je propose
d'écouter marie leur barrer catherine
svarc avocate des parties civiles
il n'est pas concevable qu'une procédure
devant la cour d'assises qui repose sur
l'oralité des débats se déroulent
derrière
un écran qui vous éloigne de toute la
science la sensation qu'on peut avoir de
ce qu'un homme vie réagit et entend de
ce que l'accusation à dire contre lui et
aussi de ce que les parties civiles ont
à dire je suis satisfaite par la
décision sage mesure et qui a été prise
par la cour et qui me paraissait pour
l'instant la seule position tenable
compte tenu de la maladie de ali riza
paul hat compte tenu de du recours en
référé liberté introduit devant le
conseil d'état contre l' ordonnance et 2
du rapport d expertise qui nous dit qu
ali riza pohlad pour un manifestement
comparaître physiquement
personnellement la semaine prochaine je
rappelle qu ali riza paulette est
suspecté de complicité avec mehdi
coulibaly son avocate maître isabelle
coûtant peyre a vivement critiqué ce
qu'elle estime être l' intervention de
l'exécutif dans ce procès on les écoute
et quand vous me voyez que monsieur
dupont moretti invoque le fait que 1
les accusés pourraient être remis en
liberté si ça durait trop longtemps il a
oublié qu'il a été avocat de la défense
et que il a oublié également la
présomption d'innocence et que ensuite
de toute façon les accusés à ce stade du
procès n'ont plus rien à faire il a
oublié que l'accusé à la parole en
dernier
et que son droit le essentiel c'est le
droit de la défense de l'accusé c'est
pas les droits de la défense de l'avocat
des droits de la défense de l'accusé
quand il demande à être présent à son
procès c'est d'y être présent le procès
reprendra donc dans une semaine si ali
riza paul hat est rétablie en sa
présence mais s'il ne l'est pas et bien
la question se reposera mais avec l'avis
du conseil d'état qui interrogé ce mardi
sur la suspension de cette ordonnance
signée par eric dupond moretti en tout
cas
l'avocate de l'accusé a fait savoir que
son client ne se prêterait jamais à un
tel dispositif